pissing open up that's the motto of
Europe's new capital of culture a
symphony composed for the occasion and
videos projected on the walls of
buildings created a magical atmosphere
during the opening show while a
tightrope walker seems to float over the
marketplace to the Cathedral
and bells sound in st. Bartholomew's
cathedral for the first time in 70 years
the old ones were melted down during the
Second World War normal of noodle famine
I'm happy that even more people are
going to visit the city this year and we
will get to talk to them and I think
it's good that there are so many events
for children and adults I think it's a
unique opportunity for the city this one
time grey industrial city has undergone
a major facelift since the end of
communism at the beginning of the 1990s
Hazen is home to 170,000 people making
it the fourth largest check city in the
historic Center listed buildings
surrounding one of Europe's biggest
market squares bear witness to pilson's
former prosperity
we would like to show that creativity is
the main driver for the change and also
it's an asset that we need to work with
to keep person an inspiring place to
live and to towards it Pearson is known
throughout the world for its beer
pilsner which was first brewed here in
1842 half a million people visit the
pilsner urquell brewery every year hello
Panama so thought of it dishonesty our
sellers are built of sandstone after
fermentation we store the beer in oak
casks here at a temperature of 4 to 6
degrees Celsius so that's what defines
the quality of our beer and it's the key
to our success Valley the butcher did it
looking at Sofia in the 19th century 260
citizens of his and joined forces to
build the cellar vaults which stretch
four kilometers they also hired use of
God that the very andrew master who
introduced a new technology for
fermentation at low temperatures and
brewed the first pilsner
pilson's best-known artists is yearly
tunica he was one of Europe's top
animation filmmakers to mark the start
of the city's year as capital of culture
and exhibition showcases the full
spectrum of his work painting puppet
making film and illustrations ed trinka
who was often described as the Walt
Disney of Eastern Europe based his art
on the Czech puppet theatre tradition
most of his films were made to appeal to
adults who have managed to preserve a
childlike view of the world what would
needlessly prepare bill chastity
government censorship of animation films
was not as strict as it was for feature
films involving actors that was an
advantage and offered my father more
freedom to realize his ideas still he
kept on coming into conflict with the
regime but he always retained his
artistic freedom for him self-censorship
was out of the question the authorities
only realized during preparations for
the events in 2015 that Austrian
architect auto floor had also left his
mark on the city he designed 13
apartments in Pigeon during the 1920s
and 30s many of them have been lovingly
restored lens ed interior if you look at
the interiors the main axis and the
subsidiary axis are always symmetrical
and another thing that's typical of our
da flosses work is that he didn't use
any artistic ornamentation only organic
ornamentation does Harper VZ heels and
that's why he used marble or wood Madame
Morrel bday were his favorite materials
/ notes designer he blinks material Ian
the wallpaper in this former office has
been restored but the furniture is not
original the apartments are already a
popular tourist attraction
Pearson open up it's a motto which is
intended to change the city for good